benim güzel bircek 9 sınıf öim jf Akar
okuluna YouTube'un en büyük jf kanalına
Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Paraf z takım okula
destek kampımızı bugün geldik 8 gününe
Türkiye'nin coğrafi konumunu GPS CBS
uzaktan algılama bu konuyu öğreneceğiz
bu konunun konu anlatımı ve soru çözüm
videosu Bu videoda tek videolu olacak
videonun sonuna doğru soru çözüm de
yapacağız Çünkü bu konu çok uzun bir
konu değil Üstüne bir de sorularımız da
da 12 soruluk bir test var İkisini O
yüzden birleştireceğiz hem konu anlatım
hem soru çözüm videosu olacak Bu arada
sınavdan sonra ilk videomuz bu bizim
sınavınız nasıl geçti sene boyunca adım
adım Tek Tek video atmıştık soru çözümü
konu anlatımı şeklinde en son bir genel
tekrar yaptım size yazılıya genel tekrar
üstne bir de yazılı örneği çözdük
İnşallah Sınavdan yüksek almışsınızdır
kaç aldıysanız yorumlara bekliyorum
yüksek almayan varsa hain kostok durur
iyi çalışmamıştır düzenli çalışın
gençler bakın böyle hafta hafta konu
atıyorum ya size bunlara düzenli çalışın
sınıfta sözünüz de yüksek olsun düzenli
çalışmazsanız olmaz bakın Biz bunu 10
sınıfta da yapacağız size Z takımı
olarak 11 sınıfta da yapacağız 12
sınıfta da yapacağız üniversite sınavı
değişecek büyük bir ihtimalle O zaman da
yine yanınızda olacağız adım adım
çalışın son zamanlara bırakmayın diyoruz
o zaman ne diyoruz Yunus hocayla bir
defa öğren bir defa asla unutma
Beğenmezsen hain koksun videoyu
beğenmeden geçme diyoruz ve gelin bu
konuya Paraf atalım geldik 8 günümüze
konumuz Türkiye'nin coğrafi konumu PDF
yine renkli bir şekilde zeda comom
sitesine yüklendi sadece benim pdf'ler
değil gençler bakın Z takımı hocalarının
bütün pdf'leri fizik kimya bioloji
matematik O sitede hemen benim pdf'ler
üst kısmında alt kısımlarında var bu
hocalarımız da yine diğer branşlarda
aynı benim yaptığım gibi adım adım
anlatım yapıyor onları da takip etmeyi
unutma Türkiye'nin coğrafi konumu şöyle
yakınlaştırıyor bakın Mutlak konum
göreceli konum Hocam şimdi konum ne
demek yani niye biz böyle bir konuma
ihtiyaç duyuyoruz diye düşündüğün zaman
şimdi sana sorsam Yerini tarif et bana
diye yani Bulunduğun yeri bana tarif et
konumunu tarif et desem Ha işte burada
konum devreye gir konum Bu yüzden önemli
bizi etkiliyor konum bulunduğumuz yerin
konumu bizim iklimimiz bile yer
şekillerini birçok şeyi etkileyebiliyor
bu yüzden konumu bilmemiz lazım yani
ülkemizin konumunu bileceğiz konumu
tarif ederken ikiye ayırıyoruz Biz bir
tanesi Mutlak konum diğeri göreceli bak
Göreceli ne demek göreceli ha bak
kelimeye bakacaksın ezberleme bunu Hım
bana göre sana göre ha bu Ülkeden ülkeye
değişiyormuş Demek ki bunun diğer bir
ismi Gençler Özel konum yani O ülkeye
özel konum bakın diğerine bakın mutlak
değişmez mutlak mutlaka olan değişmeyen
konum bu mutlaka diğer bir ismi de
Matematik konum Matematik konum gelin
Şimdi bu konumların ne demek olduğuna
bakalım şimdi Türkiye'nin mutlak konumu
Türkiye'nin matematik konumu demek
istiyor Bana yani Aklıma ne gelecek
biliyor musunuz matematik denildiğinde
Sen Türkiye'yi nasıl ifade ediyorsun
konumunu ifade ederken bana Türkiye'yi
nerede olduğunu anlat dediğim zaman
konumunu söyle dediğim zaman şöyle
diyorsun değil mi paralel ve
meridyenlerin enlem boylamların
söylemeye çalışıyorsun Bak paralel ve
meridyenler sayısal bir şey değil mi
mutlak bir şey değil mi değişmeyen bir
şey değil mi Evet Ha işte Sen eğer
paralel ve meridyenlerle enlem boylamlar
la diyelim biz Eğer sen enlem ve
boylamlar la alakalı bir şeyden
bahsediyorsan yani değişmeyen bir
şeylerden bahsediyorsan sayılardan
mutlak değişmeyen matematik olaylarından
bahsediyorsan bu mutlak konumdur
Türkiye'nin mutlak konumu nedir Bunu
bileceksin Bakın bu bu konunun en
değerli kısmı yani yazıld da sana
sorulduğunda bu konunun en değerli kısmı
ne biliyor musun Türkiye'nin mutlak
konumunu yazınız Yazabilecek misin
yazacaksın Neden Çünkü şimdi kodlayaz
onu tekrar yöntemini kullanacağız Burada
bazen şarkı söyleriz Bazen tekrar
yöntemini kullanırız bazen bir
kelimelerden bağdaşım yapar getiririz
ama bazen görselle yaparız bunu şimdi
tekrarla yapacağız bu çok değerli
benimle beraber Söylemezsen oturmaz
kafanda Bu sayıları ezberlemekle
uğraşamazsın sonra Unutursun ezberleme
benimle beraber söyle tamam mı Söyle 26
45 36 4 26 45 36 42 26 45 36 42 26 45 36
42 26 45 36 42 26 45 36 42 26 45 36 42
26 45 36 42 26 45 36 42 Söylemezsen
oturmayacak Zihnine lütfen rica ediyorum
senden söyle Bakın bu nasıl bir şey
biliyor musunuz 26 45 36 42 zihne
yerleşiyor sen Türkiye'nin coğrafi konum
26 dediğin zaman otomatik geliyor aklına
26 45 36 42 Peki hocam bunu nasıl
yerleştireceğim Bakın şimdi 26 45 diyor
bana 26 45 36 42 bakın 26 ile 45
arasında çok fazla bir sayı var orada
değil mi o zaman ne yapacaksın Bu
Türkiye nasıl şöyle doğu batı doğrultuda
uzun ha bunlar arasında çok sayı varsa o
zaman
26 45'i buraya
yerleştireceğiniz şöyle tamam Ha şöyle
3642 arasında çok fazla sayı yok E
Türkiye'nin kuzeyi ile güneyi arasında
da çok fazla öyle mesafe yok o zaman
36 42 şeklinde de böyle erişti ÇKS yani
şu burayı silelim 26 45 36 42 26 45 36
42 bakın 26 görüyor musunuz 26 doğu
meridyeni doğu boylamı 26 45 45 Doğu
boylamında geçiyoruz Türkiye
greenwich'in doğusunda olduğu için 2645
Doğu boylamları 3642 ha kısa olandı
güneyden kuzeye yerleştireceğim bakın 36
görüyor musun
36 42 26 45 36 42 Bunlar ne Kuzey
enlemleri enine çizgiler Bunlar 36 42
nasılmış Demek ki 26 45 36 42 26 45 36
42 26 45 36 42 şimdi bizim en uç
noktalarımız var bugüne kadar en uç
noktalara hiç gitmedim Gençler ben yani
o uç noktaları görmedim sinopun o ince
burun kısmına gidemedim Iğdır'ın da en
uç Iğdır'a Iğdır'a doğru gittim ama en
uç noktasına gitmedim Hatay'ın da Gökçe
adada olan yerinde ama şimdi Diyarbakır
gezisi gitmiştim ya Diyarbakır
gezisinden döndük yazılıları hazırladık
şimdi büyük bir ihtimalle Siz bu Videoyu
izlerken Çünkü ben stok çekiyorum geziye
gitmek için siz Bunları izlerken büyük
bir ihtimalle Ben geziye çıkmış olacağım
Instagram'dan Bakın bakalım çıkmış mıyım
oradan anlık takip edebilirsiniz beni
Gençler nereye neresi çıktı Biliyor
musunuz YouTube'un topluluk kısmında
anket yapıyorum oradaki şehirlere göre
gidiyoruz neresi çıktı Çanakkale çıktı
ve şu an Çanakkale'ye gideceğim
Çanakkale'de Türkiye'nin batıdaki en uç
noktasına gideceğim orası Çanakkale
burada Gökçeada Gökçeada avlaka burnuna
gideceğim gençler Evet en Türkiye'nin
batıdaki en uç noktası Gökçeada avlaka
buruna oradan size Tüh bak Keşke gitmiş
olsaydım şimdi böyle Resmini koyardım
buraya Neyse hikaye kısmında ve reals
yapacağım oraya özel rist de yapacağım
oradan bakarsınız Çanakkale'ye gidiyoruz
yeni ankette çıkan yerimiz Çanakkale Bu
arada Allah Allah'tan yakın çıktı hep
uzağa gidiyordum mesela Diyarbakır'a
gitmek İki gün sürdü Benim araba Çünkü
biraz böyle farklı bir araba olduğu için
çok zor gidiliyor İki gün sürdü
Diyarbakır'a gitmek Tokat'a orduya
gittik orası da yine biraz uzundu
Allah'tan şimdi 4 saatlik Ben şurada
Silivri'de oturuyorum Çanakkale 4
saatlik 34 saatlik yol o kadar da sürmez
de işte benim arabayla belki sürer oraya
gideceğiz bu sefer çanakkale'deyim takip
edin beni şimdi ha Türkiye'nin en
batıdaki kısmı Burası avlaka Buru Gökçe
adıda bakın en kuzeyde Sinop in burum
var çok merak ediyorum oraya da gitmedim
gideceğiz Hatay'da beysun Köyü buraya da
yine gittiğimde resim çekip atacağım
size ığdırına dil ucu Bunların hepsi bir
gün bitmiş olacak 67 sene boyunca
Türkiye'ye dolaşıyorum 67 sene boyunca
dolaşacağım her ay bir şehre gidiyorum
15 gün bir şehirde yaşıyorum 15 gün
gelip video çekiyorum size bir gün
gelecek Bunların hepsi hepsi bitmiş
olacak gençler hepsini bir reals
yapacağım Türkiye'nin en uç noktaları
diye çok güzel olacak evet Türkiye'nin
en uç noktaları bunlar Şimdi şöyle bunu
söyledik Türkiye'nin mutlak konumunun
sonuçları var yani Ne demek ben nasıl
ayıracağım Bunu sen Türkiye'yi tarif
ederken Eğer ki enlem boylamlar yani
paralel meridyenlerden bahsediyorsan
bunların sonuçlarıyla alakalı bir şeyden
bahsediyorsan bu mutlak konumun
sonucudur Bak bunu ezberleme gerek yok
Çok da dert ediyorsunuz bunu etmeyin
Eğer ki bir şey tutup saatlere gidiyorsa
Çünkü saat hesaplamalarını Biz boylamlar
arasında yapıyorduk değil mi boylamlar
meridyenler arasında sana saat
hesaplaması ile alakalı bir şey diyorsa
düşüneceksin L bu matematikle alakalı
bir şey bizim bulunduğumuz boylamlar la
alakalı bir şey E o zaman diyeceksin bu
Türkiye'nin matematik konumu mutlak
konumuyla alakalı diyeceksin Tamam ya da
işte dedi ki Türkiye'nin kuzey ile
güneyi arasında şu kadar kilometre
vardır E bu paralel bulunduğu boy şey
enlemler le alakalı bir şey değil mi o
zaman matematik konumunun sonucudur
diyeceksin Bakın şimdi en doğusu ile en
batısı arasında 76 dakika vardır E bu
geçilen boylamlar la alakalı bir şey
değil mi boylamlar arasında saat
hesaplaması yapılır O zaman bu matematik
konumun sonucu bu kadar kadar bakın + 3
saat diliminde bulunur saat dilimlerini
Biz boylamlar göre belirlemiyor muyduk
Hani 15 tane boylam geçildiğinde bir
saat dilimi falan oluyordu Evet o zaman
bu boylamla alakalı matematik konumla
alakalı bir şey bu kadar gençler hiç zor
bir şey değil bu orta enlemlerde yer
aldığı için mevsimler belirgin olarak
yaşanır bakın şunu dediğinde sana
Türkiye'de dört mevsim belirgin olarak
yaşanır dediğinde bu Türkiye'nin
matematik konumuyla alakalıdır Neden
biliyor musunuz Bakın şimdi bak şurası
ekvator çizgisi e şurası kutuplar
kutuplarda olsam sadece soğuk olacak
değil mi ekvator'da olsam sadece yaz
mevsimi yaşayacağım 12 ay boyunca yaz
mevsimi orta kuşaktayız Biz Gençler biz
orta kuşaktayız e Orta kuşakta olduğumuz
için kış yaz dört mevsimi geçiş yerinde
olduğumuz için belirgin olarak yaşıyoruz
Yani aslında dört mevsimi yaşıyor
olmamız e bizim bulunduğumuz enlem
boylamları zla alakalı mı yani
bulunduğumuz çizgilerle enine çizgilerle
alakalı bir durum değil mi İşte burada
36 enlemde değil de 90 enlemde olsaydık
o zaman Dört Mevsim yaşamayacaktır Hah
diyeceksin o zaman bu enlemle alakalı
mutlak konumla alakalı bir durum
diyeceksin Anlaştık mı bu böyle bunu
böyle yorumluyorsunuz
musunuz şurası bizim Ekvator çizgimiz
Ekvator şurası şu kesik olan çizgi ne
biliyor musunuz yengeç dönencesi Bun
öğren anlatayım sana şimdi Güneş
ışınları gençler ekvatora dik düşer
sonra kuzeye doğru gider gider gider
gider gider sonra yengeç dik düşer en
son yengeç dik düşer o zaman da 21
hazirandır 21 Haziran bizim yaz
mevsiminin başlangıcı bunu iklimlerde
Göstereceğim size bu konuyu ama şimdi
hafiften üstünden geçelim yaz mevsiminin
başlangıcıdır sonra ne oluyor biliyor
musunuz bakın Güneş böyle yengeç dik
düştü ya bakın Türkiye'ye yakın geldi
görüyor musunuz türkiyee dik
düşebülü
neye dönmeye başlıyor daha kuzeye
gidemiyor buradan güneye dönüyor bu
sefer 21 Haziran'da güneye dönmeye
Başlıyor sonra ekvatora dik düşüyor
sonra sonra güneyde oğlak dönencesi var
oğlak dönencesine gidiyor Ne oldu güneş
yengeç dönencesi ile Oğlak dönencesi
arasında böyle gitti geldi yani
Türkiye'ye Güneş dik açıyla gelebilir mi
Türkiye'ye Güneş hiçbir zaman dik açıyla
gelemez İşte nedeni bu yani sen güneşi
böyle tam tepende göremezsin güneşi
böyle hafif hafif böyle hafif eğimli bir
şekilde görürsün Evet tepeye çıkmıştır
ama eğimli bir şekilde tepeye çıkmıştır
senin tam tepene çıkamaz Güneş işte
neden senin bulunduğun enlemle alakalı
bir durum bu yani mutlak konumla alakalı
Eğer senin enlem çizgin 36 değil de
bakın şöyle sileyim Şu arada bir yerde
olsaydı Türkiye şurada olsaydı o zaman
güneş ışınları Türkiye Dik açılarla
gelebilecek di işte gençler Türkiye
güneş ışınlarının Dik açılarla
gelememesinin nedeni bulunduğu enlem
enine çizgiyle mi alakalı Evet o zaman
mutlak konumun sonucudur diyeceksin bunu
böyle yorumluyorsunuz
kuzeye gidildikçe Türkiye'de bazı şeyler
değişir ne demek hocam Mesela şöyle
bakın şurası neresi ekvator çizgisi
değil mi şimdi ekvatorla alakalı ne
biliyorsun sen güneş ınarı buraya Dik
açılarla düşüyor Ve Ekvator her dönem
yaz mevsimi yaşıyor o zaman ben Ekvator
nerede kalıyor şu güneyde o zaman burası
yaz değil mi sıcak sıcak Türkiye'nin
kuzeyine doğru gidildikçe şöyle Kuzey
tarafına da kutuplar 90 diyelim daha da
kuzeyde de görebilmen için bu ne kış
mevsimi kış mevsimi soğuk Türkiye'nin
kuzey tarafı şimdi bakın Güney güneyden
kuzeye gidildikçe Biraz daha kalın
yapalım şunu bakın güneyden kuzeye
gideceğim güneş ışınlarının düşme açısı
ve sıcaklık ortalamaları azalır bunun
mantığını öğretmeye çalışıyorum Sana
güneyden kuzeye gidiyorum e Güney
Ekvator Çünkü Ekvator var Ekvatordan
uzaklaştığım için sıcaklığım azalır Bu
neyle alakalıdır biliyor musun enlemle
alakalıdır enine çizgiyle bulunduğun
enine çizgiyle alakalı bir durum değil
mi bu enine çizgin Ekvator uzaklaştığı
için bu durum yaşanıyor O zaman bu
bulunduğun enine çizgiyle enlemle
alakalıdır diyeceksin geldim Deniz
tuzluluk oranı azalır Neden biliyor
musunuz gençler ekvator'da sıcaklıklar
fazladır Sıcaklık fazla olunca
buharlaşır su gider geride ne kalır tuz
Kalır O yüzden ekvatora yakın yerler
tuzluluk fazladır kutba gidildikçe
Türkiye'nin yani kuzeye gidildikçe kutpa
gidildikçe tuzluluk oranı azalır Çünkü
buharlaşma azalır mantığı bu Tamam bu da
Neyle alakalı gittiğim değiştirdiğim
enlemle mi alakalı bu mantık enlemle
alakalı o zaman enlem sonucudur dersin
geldim kalıcı kar sınırı yerleşme ve
tarım üst sınırı alçalır yani şu kalıcı
kar sınırı gençler çok üstler dedir
Türkiye'de Güney Ekvator kısmına doğru
yaklaştıkça kalıcı Karlar dağların en
üstlerinde kalıcı kar sınırı üsttedir
ama kuzeye gidildikçe hava soğur şöyle
kırmızı alayım hava Soğuyunca kalıcı kar
sınırı bakın şöyle aşağılara iner Çünkü
oralar artık soğuk dağın aşağı
kesimlerine iner kalıcı kar sınırının
böyle aşağılara inmesinin nedeni ne
enlem değil mi kuzeye gidiyorum
bulunduğum değiştirdiğim enlem O zaman
bu enlemin sonucu Türkiye'de güneyden
kuzeye gidildikçe nelerin değiştiğinin
mantığını Anlatıyorum sana bu mantığı
kavra kuzeyden gelen rüzgarlar sıcaklığı
düşürür neden e Kuzey Kutup kuzeyden
gelenler soğuk olur sıcaklığı düşürür e
güneyden gelenler e Ekvatordan geliyor
Rüzgar sıcak olur sıcaklığı yükseltir
Tamam Burası da tamam dağların Güney
yamaçları güneş ışınlarının Kuzey
yamaçlarına göre büyük açıyla alır biz
buna Bakı diyoruz gençler Bak şuraya bir
tane daha çizdim Bakı ne demek Bakı
Güneşe bakan taraf demek bakmak Güneşe
bakan taraf gençler güneşe her zaman
dağların ya da evlerin güneyi bakar
bizim ülkemizde yani Güney taraf güneşe
bakar Kuzey taraf güneşi göremez Şu
dağın kuzeyine Güneş hiçbir zaman
vuramaz neden E az önce anlattım sana Bu
mantıkla şurası ekvator çizgisi değil
miydi E ben buraya bir tane dağ çizsem
şöyle bir tane dağ çizdim bakın Güneş
buraya kadar geliyordu buradayken Güneş
şuradaydı vuruyor değil mi peki kuzeye
kuzeye çıktı Çıktı çıktı yengeç
dönencesine kadar çıktı buraya gelene
kadar hep ne tarafına vurdu Güney
tarafına vurdu Peki güzel E sonra
kuzeyine gidemiyor mu Hayır Güneş bu
böyle kuzeye gidebiliyor muydu kuzeye
gidebilseydim yyu Güneş Buradan sonra
dönüyor tekrar
ekvatora Ne oldu buradayken de
buradayken de buradayken de hep od dağın
güneyine vurdu Güneş o dağın Bakı güneşe
baktığı taraf hep Güney oldu işte
gençler Türkiye'de her zaman Bakı
neresidir güneydir Yani sen bir ev
almaya gideceksin diyelim ev alacaksın o
zaman Güney cephe güneşe bakar benim
Mesela bu adam güneşe bakıyor sabahtan
akşama kadar güneşe bakıyor komple
güneye bakıyor çünkü sabah bu taraftan
doğuyor akşama kadar güneş görüyor bu
oda Çünkü Bakı Güney Cephesi benim evin
Ama bunun bir de şu tarafında bir oda
var Oraya güneş hiç vurmuyor orası Kuzey
tarafa bakıyor siz de ev alırken yarın
öbür gün buna dikkat edin ya da bir ofis
kiralayacak bir iş yapacaksınız ya da
bir sanayi tesisi kuracaksınız yarın
öbür gün bir şey yapacaksınız işte
coğrafyayı Bu yüzden öğreniyorsunuz
Gençler işte bu yüzden coğrafya
öğreniyoruz o Sanayi tesisini yapacakken
o evi kuracak Ken o Çiftliği yapacakken
herhangi bir hayatta herhangi bir yer
alacakken He burası Güney Güney güneşi
görür o zaman buradan sıcaklık tasarrufu
yaparım gibi şeylere dikkat edeceksiniz
ya da bir bahçeye yapacaksın mesela
evinin önüne ya da arkasına artık Nereye
denk geliyorsa Ama sen o evi güneyine
koyup bşey de kuzeyine yaparsan ne olur
e ev gölge yapar bahçeye hiçbir zaman da
Güneş göremez o bahçe bak coğrafyanın
günlük hayattaki karşılığı işte bak iyi
Öğrendin mi Evet bunu da öğrenmiş oldun
şöyle bir sorumuz var bu soruyu ben
çözemiyorum Çünkü ÖSYM sorusu Gençler bu
soruyu şöyle bırakıyorum buraya Ekran
görüntüsü al ve üzerinde bir çalış
cevabı yorumlara bekliyorum diğer
sorularda gördüm diğer videolarda
cevapları koymuşsunuz mesela a demiş
Çoğu kişi bir soru göstermişti Güzel
doğru bir şekilde çözüyorsunuz gençler
Bu sorunun da cevabını yorumlar kısmına
koyun ben çözemiyorum Çünkü yasak Belki
buna bile telif atacak ÖSYM bilmiyorum
bu soruyu size gösterdiğim için bile
belki beni cezalandıracak ciddi para
cezaları kesiyorlar işte eğitime yani
neyse geldik bakın buraya kadar neyi
gördük Biz Türkiye'nin mutlak konumunu
gördük yani mutlak olan değişmeyen
paralel meridyen enen boylamlar la
çizgilerle alakalı olan şimdi göreceli
bana göre sana göre özel ülkeye özel
konum olacak bu sefer Yani bu Ülkeden
ülkeye değişkenlik gösterecek Buna da
özel konum diyoruz biz bu bizim gençler
birçok şeyimizi arttırıyor mesela bakın
jeopolitik ekonomik kültürel
ilişkilerimizi arttırıyor özel konumumuz
Çünkü özel konumumuz bizim komşularımızı
oluşturuyor bizim birçok şeyimizi
oluşturuyor gelin şimdi bunların
örneklerine bakalım bakın Türkiye Asya
ve Avrupa kıtalarını birleştiren
benzersiz bir konuma sahiptir bunun
altını çiz Burası önemli gençler Türkiye
nasıl bir yerde biliyor musunuz şuraya
bakar mısınız bizim Türkiye Hani diyoruz
ya Türkiye'nin toprakları altın
değerinde ve Türkiye çok değerli bir
yerde diyoruz ya nedeni bu bizim özel
konumumuz la alakalı bir durum ne demek
Hocam bakın şu gördüğünüz Hazar var ya
Petrol doğalgaz rezervlerinin bulunduğu
yer Asya Kıtası aynı zamanda burası şu
gördüğünüz Basra Körfezi şu gördüğünüz
burada Afrika kıtası bakın Bütün bu
yerler Petrol doğal gazın Merkezi şurası
e burası Petrol doğal gazın Merkezi E bu
Petrol doğal gazı kim alacak Avrupalılar
alacak onların o kadar Petrol doğal gazı
yok E Avrupa nerede burada Türkiye
nerede Avrupa la Bakın şu şekilde
Asya'nın güneyde Afrika'nın birleşim
noktasında Türkiye bir geçiş geçiş
güzergahında Bu yüzden gençler
Türkiye'nin konumu çok değerli oluyor
buralarda Petrol için savaşlar oluyor
Türkiye'nin değeri ortaya çıkıyor yine
de Türkiye'nin söyleyeceği sözler
değerli hale geliyor buralarda
kargaşalar oluyor Türkiye'nin değeri
ortaya çıkıyor buralardan Petrol doğal
gaz nasıl geçecek e Türkiye üzerinden
geçecek Türkiye burada çok değerli bir
konumda bu Türkiye'nin etrafının Avrupa
ve Asya'nın geçiş güzergahı üzerinde
olması bir köprü görevi görmesi Mutlak
konum mu özel konum mu bize özel konum
değil mi o zaman bu göreceli konum bunun
göreceli konumun sonucu tamam Bakın
Mesela bizim komşularımız var Ermenistan
Gürcistan Doğu kesimde Azerbaycan
Nahçıvan kısmı var Orada işte İran Irak
Suriye Yunanistan değil mi Bulgaristan
Bakın bu ülkelere komşu olmamız paralel
meridyenlerle alakalı bir şey mi Hayır
bu bize özgü bir şey değil mi bize özgü
bir şey bize özel bir şey o zaman bu
göreceli konum bizim komşularımız bizim
göreceli konumumuz Mesela bu göreceli
konumun avantajları var ne Bunlar Afrika
Asya'nın birleştiği noktadayız enerji
taşıyabiliyor Bu sayede bakın şurada
boru hatlarıyla beraber tanap projesi
trans Anadolu projesi bu gençler bakın
Azerbaycan'dan gelen doğal gazı Biz
Gürcistan üzerinden bizim ülkemizden
geçiyor Bakın bu kadar topraklarda bizim
ülkemizden geçtiği için biz de bundan
faydalanıyoruz Böylece buradan Avrupa'ya
doğru gidiyor enerjinin taşınma
noktasında güzergahında Bu bize avantaj
sağlıyor bizim üç tarafımız denizlerle
çevrili e her tarafta deniz var
Denizcilik gelişebilir e Balıkçılık
balık oluyor bu sayede Bu da bize bir
avantaj sağlıyor ama burada İstanbul ve
Çanakkale boğazları var bakın üç
tarafımız denizlerle çevrili ama bir de
burada İstanbul Boğazı Şurada da
Çanakkale Boğazı var E buradaki ülkeler
e nereden geçmek zorunda bizim
boğazlarımız dahan geçmek zorunda işte
bakın bizim ülkemizin değerini tekrar
ortaya Çıkartıyor bu avantajlarımız bir
tanesi özel konum Biz jeolojik
bakımından gençler şunu unutmuyorsun
genç oluşumlu bir ülkeyiz yani
tersiyerde senozoik de oluştuk biz genç
oluşumlu yeni oluştuk yeni oluştuğu için
daha böyle dağlık engebeli yiz akarsular
bizi böyle aşıp ta taşındır
düzleştirmede genç dinamik genç insanlar
nasıl olur dinamik ve hareketli olur
değil mi Bizim ülkemiz de böyle
hareketli deprem sahası Bu yüzden bizim
ülkemiz genç oluşumlu Bu yüzden de
deprem
sahasındaki bakımından zenginiz O yüzden
su kaynak kayakları bakımından zengin
değiliz ama sıcak su kaynakları
bakımından zenginiz Neden Çünkü
depremlerin olduğu yerlerde kırıklar var
bu kırıklardan içeri su gidiyor o su alt
kesimlerde yerin alt kesimlerinde ısınıp
yüzeye çıkıyor bizim ülkemiz genç
oluşumlu olduğu için deprem bölgesi
deprem bölgesi olduğu için kırıklar var
ve bu Kırıklarda sıcak sular ortaya
çıkıyor kaplıcalar sıcak sular
bakımından zenginiz bizim ülkemiz ciğer
şekilleri bakımından en Gebeli ve
ortalama yükseltisi fazla niye genç
oluşumlu yuz bunu bilmen lazım Senin
yorumlamalar çok işimize yarayacak bu
bilgiler Evet aynı zamanda ülkemizde ne
var gençler çok farklı kültürler var
inanamazsınız Diyarbakır'a bir gittim o
kadar kültürel farklılık ve çeşitlilik
var ki yani Ege'ye gidiyorsunuz eski
Yunan kültürüyle alakalı bir sürü şeyler
görüyorsunuz Diyarbakır'a gittim
Ermenilerle alakalı çok ciddi kültürel
olarak eski kültürlere ait yapılar var
mesela Diyarbakır Eğil ilçesine gittim
peygamberlerin mesela birçok peygamberin
orada yaşadığı söyleniliyor bakıyorsunuz
o kadar mümkün ki böyle bakıyorsunuz
dağa dağ böyle resmen bir şehir
kurmuşlar dağın altında dağın altı böyle
kesik bir şekilde yandan görülüyor
resmen bir şehir kurmuşlar dağın altına
gidiyorsunuz mesela Diyarbakır'a orada
Çayönü var çay önü dediğimiz ilk
yerleşmelerin ortaya çıktığı yer Ya
insanların ilk yerleşme bütün dünyada
insanların ilk yerleştiği yerler ya ilk
köy yerleşmesinin olduğu yer ve bu o
kadar belli ve variz ki Düşünsenize İlk
insanların yerleşime geçtiği yer orası O
yerleşimin hemen yanında mağaralar var
diyorsunuz ki ya o kadar belli ki
mağaralara bakıyorsunuz Ya ilk insan bu
mağaralarda yaşamışlar çok belli
diyorsunuz o ilk zamanlardaki insanlar
ya o kadar kültürel zenginliğimiz var ki
o Mezopotamya'da İlk insanların yaşadığı
yerler geliyorsunuz Ege kısmına Antalya
kısmına Akdeniz kısmına Yunanlıların
kültürlerini görüyorsunuz Türk
kültürlerini görüyorsunuz Birçok yerde o
kadar zengin ki bizim ülkemiz bu konuda
evet şu soruyu Biz çözebiliriz aşağıdaki
coğrafya özelliklerden hangisi
Türkiye'nin göreceli konumuyla ilgili
değildir göreceli konum özel Bize özel
olacak değil mi yer şekillerinin en
Gebeli yüksek olması bir bize özel bir
şey bu bize özgü bir şey en Güveli
dağlık bir ülkeyiz evet bize özel bak Üç
tarafı denizlerle çevrili bize özgü bir
şey bu tarih boyunca birçok
Medeniyetleri ev sahip yaptı Bizim
ülkemize özel bir şey bu belki
Yanımızdaki ülke tarih boyunca birçok
medeniyeti ev sahipliği yapmadı bize
özel bir şey doğusuyla batısı arasında
yerel saat farkı 76 dakika Bak burada
boylamlar la alakalı bir bilgi vermiş ha
bu değişmeyen mutlak konumla alakalıdır
diyeceksin o zaman bu soruları böyle
çözüyorsun işte Asya Afrika kıtasını
birbirine bağlayan doğal köprü görür
bize özel bir şey bu cevap D buna böyle
bakacaksınız Gençler bu sorulara çok
basittir gelelim şimdi bunları yapalım
pekiştirelim kıyı kesimlerinin İç
kesimlere göre daha fazla yağış alması
bu bizim bak kıyı içeri gidince yağışlar
azalıyor niye karasallığın bize özel bir
şey değil mi bu bana özel bir şey bu
bizim ülkemize özel bir şey o zaman
benim göreceli konumumla alakalı bir
durum şöyle yapalım tik atalım ya da yok
şöyle boyayalım Evet şöyle kalınlaştır
şunu boyaması kolay olsun ekonomik
bakımdan farklı ülkeler arasında yer
alır Ee benim özel konumumla alakalı Sağ
ol sağda şu ülke var solumda bu ülke var
kuzeyinde şu ülke var Benim özelliğim le
alakalı bir durum özel konum göreceli
konum yıl boyunca ı 3 saat dilimi bak
saatler boylamlar la alakalı bir durum
yani benim bulunduğum boylamla alakalı
boylam değişmez mutlak Matematik konum O
zaman diyeceksin doğusu ile batısu
arasında yaklaşık 1 saat 16 dakika var E
bu boylamlar la
hesaplıyo Mutlak konum oluyor Bakın bu
kadar basit bunu yorumlamak ORT Doğu
Kafkasya enerji hatları Avrupa'ya boru
hatları taşınır ülkemizden bize özgü bir
şey bu bunun enlem boylamla bir alakası
yok O zaman özel konum kıyılarda
güneyden kuzeye doğru gidildikçe
sıcaklık ortalamalarının azalması
kuzeyden güneyden kuzeye gidildikçe
sıcaklık düşer diyor şimdi düşünüyorum
Güney ekvatora yakın he sıcak Kuzey
kutuplara yakın soğuk bu enlemle alakalı
bir şey bak değiştirdiğim enlem
çizgileri ile alakalı bir değişim var
burada o zaman bu çizgiyle alakalı enlem
boylamla mutlak konumla alakalı bir
durum diyorum Asya Afrika ve Avrupa
kıtalarının birbirine en çok yaklaştığı
yerde bulunur Bana özel bir şey bu enlen
boylamlar akı değil özel konum kuzeyden
isen Rüzgar sıcaklığı düşürür kuzeyden
Kuzey enleminden gelen Rüzgar soğuk
Güney enleminden gelen Rüzgar sıcak
benim bulunduğum çizgiyle alakalı bir
durum bu değil mi ekvator'da olsaydım
hep sıcak olacaktı o zaman bulunduğum
enlemle yani mutlak konumla farklı
kültür medeniyetleri beşiklik etmesi
yani bana özel bir şey bu enlem ya da
boylamla alakalı bir durum değil özel
konum sıradağların güney yamaçlarının
kuzey yamaçlardan daha sıcak olması
Güney niye sıcaktı Çünkü Güneş güneyden
vuruyordu E ben Türkiye'yi alıp ekvatora
koysam Güneş hem kuzeye hem güneye vurur
Demek ki güneşin sadece güneye vurması
bulunduğum enlem çizgisi ile alakalı
bulunduğum çizgilerle alakalı O zaman bu
matematik konumun sonucu Tamam buraya
kadar Tamam geldik şimdi mavi Vatan
kısmına biri bize mavi Vatan dediğinde
aklımıza hemen sularımız gelecek Mavi
diyor bak Buradan çağrışım yapacaksın
mavi Vatan sular Mavi Su ha sular
üzerindeki gücümüzü ifade ediyor Bu
bizim Deniz yetki alanlarımızı ifade
ediyor Yani birinize mavi Vatan
dediğinde bizim Akdeniz'deki o kendi Eee
kıta sağlığımızı korumamız Deniz yetki
alanımız ha bak denizlerde buraya kadar
Burası bizim sınırımız bu gölleri de
kapsıyor akarsuları da kapsıyor Tabii ki
bütün sularımızı kapsıyor ama daha çok
biz bunu gençler Deniz yetki
alanlarımızda kullanıyoruz mavi Vatan
olayı da ne zaman ortaya çıktı daha çok
biliyor musunuz şurada Akdeniz'de Biz
doğalgaz Petrol aramaya başladık denizde
bu denizlerde Petrol ararken bu bizim
için değerli oldu mavi Vatan dedik Tamam
mavi Vatan kısmı da bu şimdi mavi Vatan
daha çok sulardaki stratejik o sınırları
ifade ediyor ama şu bizim için şu
bilgileri de bir görmen lazım yani tamam
suları strateji olarak kıta sağınlı mızı
ifade ediyor ama vatan savunmasına da
gelir bu değil mi kıta sağınlı mız
oradaki sulardaki Vatan savunmasını da
ifade ediyor kıyıların güvenliği Deniz
stratejik önemi uluslararası
ilişkilerden kaynaklanan hakları Çünkü
bu denizler uluslararası ilişkilerle
korunuyor belirli bir mile kadar sizin
sayılıyor enerji kaynaklarını kullan
ifade eder denizlerde de Çünkü enerji
kaynaklarımız var mavi Vatan Bu bir de
Gök Vatan var E o da adı üstünde bak Gök
Vatan göklerdeki sınırımızı ifade ediyor
göklerde sınır mı var hocam Evet Gençler
her ülkenin bir hava sahası var ve Başka
ülkeler öyle Hava sahasına Lap diye
giremezler yani Gelip Yunanistan bizim
Türkiye'nin hava sahasına giriş yapamaz
biz onu vurabiliriz mesela bir uçağa
gelse Türkiye'nin hava sahasına öyle
giriş yapamaz kafasına göre izin almalı
bunu bildirmeli geçeceğim sizin
ülkenizin üstüne vesaire demeli öyle
kafasına göre ülkenin hava sahasına
giriş yapamaz Gök Vatan da bizim hava
sahasındaki sınırlarımızı ifade eder
geldik Kıbrıs adasına Kıbrıs Adası
gençler çok değerli bir yer bu Osmanlı
döneminde de çok ciddi sıkıntılara neden
olmuş en son İngilizlere geçmiş
ingilizlerden sonra İngiltere'ye Biz bir
ara bırakmıştık onu ondan sonra tekrar
Ecevit zamanında gittik oraya çıkartma
yaptık ve en son adanın yarısı Kuzey
Kıbrıs Türk Cumhuriyeti orada kuruldu
Tabii dünyada devletler bunu kabul
etmiyor ama biz bunu böyle kabul
ediyoruz ve bu şu an orada da öyle ikili
bir durum var Rum Kesimi var Türk kesimi
var şimdi niye bu kadar önemli Kıbrıs
gençler Kıbrıs Akdeniz'in geçiş
güzergahında bakın Kıbrıs burada şurada
güvenlik için çok değerli bizim Şuradaki
limanlarımız güvenliği için Akdeniz'in
geçiş kısmındaki Buradaki en önemli
adalardan bir tanesi o yüzden değerli
bir yerde aynı zamanda Siz buraya Sahip
olduğunuz zaman E buradan da deniz mili
olarak sizin sınırını oluşturuyor bazı
yerler Bu yüzden de sizin Deniz
sınırlarınız genişliyor Bunun için de
önemli Kıbrıs'ın önemi ne zaman arttı
biliyor mus Bor musunuz bu soru bize
böyle gelebilir Kıbrıs'ın önemi zaten
her zaman vardı ama şurada süve kanalı
var bak Süveyş Kanalı geçmişte Süveyş
Kanalı açılmadığında insanlar tarafından
gemiler şuradan güneyden Afrika'nın
güneyinden dolaşıyorlardı Süveyş Kanalı
açılınca artık gemiler buradan gelip bu
şekilde geçiş yapıyorlar sç kanalında E
şimdi gemiler Buradan daha fazla geçince
daha fazla trafik olunca Kıbrıs'ın önemi
de artmış oluyor Bunu unutmayın Evet
geldik mekansal bilgi teknolojilerinin
bileşenleri kısmına gençler şurada gbs
Coğrafi Bilgi Sistemleri demek bu bizim
için değerli adı üstüne Coğrafi Bilgi
Sistemleri ne demek Hocam bu Coğrafi
Bilgi Sistemleri Aslında şunun üzerinden
bunu net bir şekilde aktarabilirim size
şu önceden şöyle düşünün bir harita
çizili oldu değil mi bir taslak çizili
oldu elle sonra gidiliyordu arazide
çalışma yapılıyordu ve bu taslağın
üzerine veriler işleniyordu elle beraber
işte gittik Petrol için gittik Mesela
bir araziye haritamız var bu haritaya
Petrol yerlerini işliyordu biz artık
teknol değişti gelişti artık her şeyi
teknoloji üzerinden yapabiliyoruz ve
bunu bu
haritalaması ve katman katman
istediğimiz verileri koyup çıkartabilmek
işte gbs CBS Coğrafi Bilgi Sistemleri
yani şu açıyorsunuz Bu bir program
yazılım programı açıyorsunuz şu bir şu
bir ilk önce bir altlık oluşturuyorsunuz
haritanın altlığı ilk harita böyle
düşünün sonra bunun üzerine aldığınız
verileri istediğiniz veriyi tek tek
koyup işleyebiliyor musunuz bu çok güzel
bir şey mesela oranın evde erini görmek
istiyorsunuz binalarını görmek
istiyorsanız bir yer tıkları tık tık tık
kapatıyorsunuz tık binaları açıyorsunuz
O yerin bina haritası çıkıyor önünüze
onun çıktısını alıyorsunuz istediğiniz
yerde kullanın binaları değil ağaçları
da içerisine koyabiliyorsan işte bununla
alakalı Sadece bina ağaç olarak
düşünmeyin bunu bitkileri jeolojisi
iklimleri bütün hepsinin verilerini
istediğiniz gibi tık tık tık koyup koyup
çıkartıp istediğiniz haritaları
oluşturabiliyorsunuz CBS sistemi bunu
sağlıyor işte yani geçmişteki elle
yapılan bu veri işlemesi ve haritaların
günümüzde bilgisayar ortamına çok ciddi
profesyonel bir şekilde aktarılması gbs
sisteminin şurada unsurları var bir
kullanıcı olması lazım bir veri
koyacağız içine bir donanım olacak
bunları bir donanım üzerinde yapmanız
gerekiyor bir bilgisayar telefon vesaire
işte bunun bir yazılım kısmı var
arkadaki yazılım kısmı Bir de bunu
yöneten kişi var Yani bu başlıklar belki
cbs'nin unsurlarını yazınız şeklinde
sorulabilir size en fazla bu burada
uzaktan algılama dediğimiz şey uydular
yardımıyla Biz fotoğrafından videosuna
birçok şeyi artık uydular yardımıyla
uzaktan algılayarak verileri elde
edebiliyoruz buna uzaktan algılama
deniyor uydular var dünyanın üstünde
biliyorsunuz burada yüksek çözünürlüklü
verileri birçok veriyi rahatla buradan
ulaşabiliyor uzaktan algılama sistemi
dediğimiz sistem bu Bunlar gençler
bildiğimiz şeyler genelde Şuradaki GPS
şimdi GPS konum belirleme değil mi Bizim
kullandığımız navigasyonlar da GPS
sistemi üzerinden çalışıyor Mesela
gps'li olay konum belirleme ve bununla
alakalı şöyle bir ek bilgi vereyim size
GPS sistemi Amerika Birleşik Devletleri
aittir gençler şu an biz GPS
kullanıyoruz ya Amerika'nın GPS istese
kapatabilir onun kurduğu sistemlerle şu
an işliyor GPS Biz sanıyoruz ki genelde
bu GPS sanki bütün herkese açıkmış gibi
hani bir ülkeye ait değilmiş gibi ama
Amerika'ya ait Bu sivil Kullanıma bizim
kullanımıda böyle rahatlıkla açık askeri
kullanımlarda da yine ülkeler
kullanıyorlar ama Amerika istediği zaman
mesela bunu kapatabilir biliyor musunuz
bu çok önemli O yüzden diğer devletler
de bu GPS sistemine benzeyen şeyler
yapmaya çalışmışlar ama çok
kullanılmıyor Genelde biz GPS biliyoruz
mesela neydi Avrupa'nın Galileo Galileo
oluşturduğu Rusya'da bir tane oluşturmuş
ama ismi aklımda değil mesela Galileo
Hiç duymadın ama GPS'i hepimiz biliyoruz
Avrupa'da güvenliği askeri güvenliği
için vesaire öyle bir sistem yapmış
Çünkü Amerika yarın bize dese ki mesela
çok kötü oldu kullanamazsınız dese
kullanamayız sıkıntılı bir durum Yani
aslında bu GPS ne konum belirlemeyi
sağlıyor navigasyonda kullanıyoruz bunu
gidiyoruz hayvanların boğazlarına mesela
balinalara köpek balıklarına birçok
hayvanı takip etmek için bir şey
takıyorlar bir GPS sistemi takıyorlar
nerelere gittiğin vesaire takip
edebiliyorlar Bisikletçiler doğal
sporları yapanlar kullanıyorlar bunu
nerelere gittiklerini gpsler le beraber
izleriyle beraber harita oluşturuyorlar
Evet GPS bunun için kullanılıyor bütün
kısmını söyledik ne kullanıyor GPS'i
bileşenleri Bana göre çok önemli değil
ama söyle GPS'i bileşenlerinde ne var
yukarıda uydular var gençler yeryüzünde
Kontrol Merkezi antenler var E bizim
kullandığımız telefonlar var Bunlar
arasında veriler gidip geliyor ve biz
bunları kullanıyoruz GPS sisteminde bu
var mekansal verilerin haritalar
aktarılmasında kullanılan yön yöntemler
nelerdir
GPS
CBS uzaktan algılama uzaktan
algılama diyoruz ve gelin şimdi test
sorularını çözelim konu anlatımını
bitirdik 12 tane sorumuz var Bunları da
çözüp tamamen oturtalım konuyu gençler
kitabın sayfa 43 sayfasını açıyorsunuz
şöyle 1ci sorudan başlayalım hangi
öğrencinin verdiği yanıt Doğrudur 9
sınıf coğrafi öğretmeni Mehmet Bey
öğrencilerin bir yerin ekvatora ve
başlangıç merid Yerine göre yeri neyi
ifade eder şek şeklinde soru sormuş şu
yanıtları almıştır bak bir yerin
başlangıç meridyeni diyor ekvatora göre
konumu diyor e başlangıç meridyeni
burada Ekvator burada buraya göre konumu
enlem boylamların söylüyor bize değil mi
enlem boylamların dan kastımız ne mutlak
konumunu söylüyor bize yani cevabımız a
geçelim diğer soruya Görece konun bir
yerin denizlere okyanuslara önemli
ticaret Yollarına farklı ekonomik ve
siyasi topluluklara göre konumudur bu
bilgileri dikkate alındığında Aşağıda
verilen göreceli konum şartlarından
hangisinin sadece Türkiye'ye ait olduğu
söylenebilir Karadenizli kıyısı var
Hayır yani o tarafta Gürcistan'ın da
Karadenizli kıyısı var değil mi
Bulgaristan'ın da Karadenizli kıyısı var
sadece Türkiye'ye ait olacak diyor Asya
kıtasında yer alması Türkiye'nin Anadolu
toprakları Asya kıtasında Bu sadece
Türkiye'ye ait mi Hayır birçok ülke var
Asya'da birinci derecede deprem bölgesi
olması bu sadece Türkiye'ye ait bir
durum mu birinci derece deprem bölgesi
olan bir sürü ülke var Japonya'da
birinci derece deprem bölgesi ticaret
yolları üzerinde yer alması sadece
Türkiye mi ticaret yolu üzerinde e İran
da Türk ticaret yolu üstünde olabilir
Yunanistan da ticaret yolu üstünde
olabilir ama isan İstanbul Çanakkale
boğazlarına sahip olması sadece
Türkiye'ye ait Göreceli bir konu Yani bu
göreceli konum sadece Türkiye'ye özel
bir şey cevapa geçelim diğer soruya
aşağıd hangisi Türkiye'nin Çeşitli
kaynaklarda konumu tarif edilirken
kullanılan adlandırmalar biri değildir
gençler Türkiye ön Asya'da yer alır bu
güzel bir soru buradan bilgi öğrenelim
güneybatı Asya kısmında yer alır bak
güneybatı Türkiye Batı kısmında değil mi
Asya küçük Asya kısmında da yer alıyoruz
Ortadoğu denildiğinde bazı ayrımlara
göre Türkiye Ortadoğu'nun içerisinde de
var bazı ayrımlara göre yok ama
Güneydoğu Asya'da yokuz güneydoğu Asya
Asya'nın güneydoğusu Güneydoğu Asya'dan
kast Hindistan Çin o taraf güneydoğu
Asya Türkiye orada değil cevap D geçelim
diğer soruya Mutlak konum Herhangi bir
yerin enlem boylamların belirlenen
konumdur Türkiye 2645 36 42'de ydi değil
mi 2645 36 42 26 45 36 42 aşağı hangisi
Türkiye'nin mutlak konumunun
sonuçlarından biri değildir mutlak
matematik bakalım bitk örs ve tarımsal
etkinliklerin çeşitlilik göstermesi
gençler bitk Örs niye çeşitlilik
gösteriyor tarımsal etkinlikler mesela
Dört Mevsim olduğu için tarımda da çok
farklı tarım çeşidimiz oluyor değil mi
mesela sadece ekvator'da olsak o kadar
tarım çeşidimiz olmaz Demek ki bizim
Orta kuşakta olmamız bulunduğumuz enlem
tarımsal çeşitliliğimiz etkiliyor bu da
mutlak bulunduğumuz enlemle alakalı bir
durum Akdeniz kıyılarının da Deniz
turizminin gelişmesi Çünkü Akdeniz
ekvatora yakın e bak enlemini söyledim
Ekvator yakın olduğu için dedim o zaman
bulunduğu enlemle alakalı bir durum
enlemle mutlak konumla alakalı en Kuzey
ile en güney arasında 606 km Ee
enlemlerin arasındakileri saymış
matematikle alakalı bir şey koymuş
buraya matematik konomi Mutlak konum yer
şekillerinin çeşitlilik göstermesi Bu
benim bulunduğum çizgiyle alakalı bir
durum değil ki enlem boylamla bu bana
özel bir şey yer şekillerin çeşitlilik
gösteriyor Çünkü genç oluşumlu bir
ülkeyim dağlık engebeli yim Bana özel
bir konum bu Maki üst sınırının
Antalya'dan Bursa'ya doğru gidildikçe
alçalması makilerin yaşadığı üst sınır
Bursa'ya gidildikçe daha aşağılara
kayıyor daha yukarılarda makiler
yetişemiyor Çünkü sıcaklık düşüyor E bu
sıcaklık düşmesi ekvator'dan uzaklaşmaya
kutuplara yakınlaşmaya alakalı Yani
bulunduğumuz enlem çizgisiyle alakalı
değiştirdiğimiz enlemle alakalı O zaman
bu enlem cevabımız D geçelim diğer
soruya aşağıd hangisi Türkiye'nin mutlak
konumuyla açıklanır 2 ve 3 saat
diliminde bulunması mutlak matematik bir
şey değil mi matematikle alakalı değil
mi boylama göre yapmıyor muyuz Bunu o
zaman Matematik konum Tamam iklim
çeşitliliğinin fazla olması bak Dört
Mevsim demiyor bak Dört Mevsim yaşaması
başka bir şey bak bunu unutma yaz kış
ilkbahar sonbahar bunlar dört mevsim
yaşaması bulunduğumuz enlemle alakalı
ama iklim çeşitliliği diyor İklim
çeşitliliği başka yani Akdeniz iklimi
karasal iklim bu Karadeniz iklimi
bunları yaşamamızın nedeni ülkemizin yer
şekilleriyle alakalı bir durum deniz
kenarında Akdeniz yaşıyoruz tık hemen
dağ çıkıyor karasal iklime geçiyoruz
hemen arkaya dağ geliyor bak bu Benim
özelliğim de dağlık engebeli bir ülke
olduğumuz için aşağıda Akdeniz var Hemen
yukarı çıkıyoruz karasal içeri giriyoruz
sert karasal Yani bu aslında ülkenin yer
şekilleriyle özelliğiyle özel konumuyla
alakalı bir durum stratejik öneminin
fazla olması bana özgü bir şey
Gelişmekte olan ülkeler grubunda olmak
ülkemize özgü paralel meridyenlerle
alakalı bir şey değil deprem riskinin
yüksek olması deprem fay Hatta olduğu
için bulunduğum enlemle alakalı bir
durum değil cevap A geçelim diğer soruya
bir ülkenin dünya üzerindeki yeri ifade
edilirken coğrafi konumundan diğer bir
ifadeyle mutlak ve göreceği konum
özelliklerinden yararlanılır göreceli
konumla ilgili ifadelerden hangileri
doğrudur özel bana özel olacak
insanların bölgeye ilişkin algılama
algılarına dayandığından bir yerin
konumunu belirle in daha öznel bir
yoludur göreceli konum öznel bir şeydir
değişir kişiden kişiye Ülkeden ülkeye
değişir doğru bir yerin dünya üzerindeki
üzerinde nerede bulunduğunun kesin
olarak tanımlanmasını sağlar kesin mi
sağlar Hayır mutlak konumu diyor burada
bu yanlış kesin sağlamaz özel bir şey
çevredeki ortam değiştikçe veya yeni
yerler geliştikçe zaman içerisinde
değişir Evet çünkü bir sanayi
faaliyetinin yanındasın o Sanayi
faaliyeti oradan çıkar sen artık o
sanayiyi kullanarak Özel konumunu ifade
edemezsin değişir 1 ve 3 cevapa geçelim
diğer soruya Aşağıda verilenlerden
hangisi Türkiye'nin stratejik önemini
arttıran özelliklerden biri değildir
Karadeniz ad Denizi ve akdeniz'le
Çevreli olması bize stratejik bir güç
Sağlar değil mi Deniz çevre denizlerimiz
olması bize stratejik güç sağlar Asya ve
afr kıtalarını birbirine bağlıyoruz bize
stratejik olarak güç sağlar yükselti
fazda yer şekillerinin engebeli olması
Gençler bu bize stratejik olarak avantaj
değil Biraz dezavantaj sağlıyor Çünkü
yol yapmak zorlaşıyor ulaşım zorlaşıyor
bir bizim için biraz Dez dez avantaj
Tabii Avantajları da var Bu durumun ama
stratejik olarak bize stratejik önemim
ii arttırmıyor bu Bor hatlarıyla geçtiği
için enerji koridoru dur stratejimiz
gücümüz artar kıtalararası ticaret
yollarının kesişim noktası e ticaret
geçecek stratejimiz gücümüz artar
cevapçı geçelim diğer soruya uzaktan
algılama teknolojinin görüntüleri uydu
uçaklar ve çeşitli hava araçlarıyla elde
edilir geniş alanları gösteren bu
fotoğraflardan çevre analizleri
yapılabilir hangisi bu fotoğrafların
analizlerinden belirlenemez yeryüzü
şeklini fotoğraf çektik yeryüzü şeklini
buluruz yerleşim alanlarını yukarıdan
fotoğraf çektik yerleşim alanlarını
buluruz bitki örtüsünü görürüz değil mi
fotoğrafa böyle Bakarak arazi
kullanımını nasıl yapmışlar buluruz
mevsimsel iklim değişmelerini iklimlerin
değişmelerini yıllara göre fotoğraflara
bakarak görmemiz zor veriler toplamamız
lazım cevapa geçelim diğer soruya
Coğrafi Bilgi Sistemleri Doğal ortam
insan ve zaman ilişkisine ait veri
toplama depolama ve analiz çalışmaları
ile elde edilen mekansal bilgilerin
harita tablo ve grafiklerle
görüntülenmesinde imkan sağlayan
bilgisayar tabanlı bilg yönetimidir
aşağı hangisi bu yöntemin
bileşenlerinden değildir kullanıcı vardı
değil mi yazılımcı lazım veri lazım
yöntem lazım ama GPS alıcısı o başka bir
şey GPS sistemi başka bir şey CBS
sistemi başka bir şey o onun bir yapısı
değil cevap C geçelim diğer soruya
küresel konumlandırma sistemi uydular
yer kontrol istasyonu ve GPS alıcısı
arasında iletilen Radyo sinyalleri ile
çalışır uydulardan konum belirlemeye
dayalı bu teknolojinin kullanım alanları
arasında Aşan hangisi yoktur insansız
hava araçları GPS sistemini kullanır
navigasyon gibi düşünün banka ATM'leri
GPS sistemiyle konumlarını takip ediyor
insanlar hani Banka ATM'si
kaçırıldığında içinde GPS var takip
edebiliyorsun arabalara da GPS takılıyor
arabaları takip etmek için arama
kurtarma çalışmalarında GPS kullanılıyor
yer deniz ve hava araçlarındaki
navigasyonlarda yine var sözel veri
toplama amacıyla yapılan anket
anketlerde GPS ne alakası var cevap
geçelim diğer soruya coğrafi bilginin
hızla artması mekansal bilgilerin
yönetiminde bilgisayar teknolojilerinden
yararlanmayı zorunlu hale getirmiştir
coğ bilgi sistemleri bu ihtiyacı
karşılamak için geliştirilmiştir aşağı
hangisi Bu sistemin özellikleri arasında
gösterilemez CBS konumsal verilere
dayalı haritaların üretilmesi Evet
konumlara göre harita üretebiliriz bir
yerdeki Farklı coğrafi unsurlara ait
bilgilerin ayrı katmanlar halinde
haritalanması
sağlar Evet birçok veriyi gördüğümüz
için analiz yapabiliriz haritada mekanla
ilgili çalışmalarda karar destek sistemi
olarak kullanılması Evet önümüzdeki bir
çalışmayı görüp burada karar vermek için
bize bir destek oluşturabilir bu veriler
haritalar yalnızca konumun konunun
uzmanları tarafından kullanılması Hayır
bu haritaları sadece konunun uzmanları
değil herkes kullanabilir gençler cevap
bunu bitirdik bu konuyu Evet ikinci
ünitenin sonuydu bu Bu ikinci ünitenin
sonuydu 1ci ve 2ci üniteyle alakalı test
soruları da bir genel tekrar yine
yaparız ikinci iki ünitenin kapsadığı
burada ünite Eee Bir ünite ölçme
testleri var bunlarla beraber bir genel
tekrar yine yaparız artık 3 ünite
geçiyoruz 3üncü ünitede bizi iklim
konusu bekliyor 3ün ünite biraz
zorlayıcı bir ünite olabilir sizin için
günü gününe çalışmayı unutmayın artık
ikinci üniteyi bitirdik ikinci üniteyi
de Paraf attık 3üncü ünitede görüşmek
üzere